après ma vidéo sur les vieux et la
technologie j'ai eu besoin de dieu qui
m'ont fait bien vu la vidéo traduction
va bien de ferran et fils 2 et je me
suis dit qu'en fait les jeunes et la
technologie c'est bien court aussi
facile berceau comme en super tôt les
gamins veulent tous un téléphone
portable
et l'argument imbattable consorts pour
en avoir un c'est une sage pour accabler
si je tiens même plutôt ou si j'ai un
problème
bon d'accord à gagner tu ferais
attention c'est mon premier téléphone
portable
je crois que le jeune et téléphone
portable c'est devenu indissociable
aujourd'hui moi tu m'enlèves mon
téléphone je suis en panique en ville et
mon bordel où tu arrives tu as you
d'ailleurs parfois je me fais des petits
coups de stress attendre you mon
téléphone est en train de chercher ton
téléphone dans ta poche alors fuir dans
la main revenir [ __ ] j'suis combat oui
c'est qu'on est il en train de chercher
à se tailler pas dans la poche arqiva
dans la main on se regarde moi ce qu'on
la maternelle il ya un autre truc qui me
stresse avec les téléphones profondes au
maroc
je sais pas pourquoi quand je vois un
téléphone qu'à 1% de batterie ça me met
dans un état de stress et de panique
totale
tu veux pas en changer j'ai plus de
batterie c'est un genre de chez moi je
me faire renverser je tombe alors je
peux m'appeler ce coin il décède et tu
peux plus jouer à convaincre au genou
plus je recharge est alors ouais c'est
pourquoi il ya qu un seul chargeur pour
de téléphone alors la parité un chargeur
ah non mais j'en ai qu'un et puis il
faut je cherche mon téléphone on est
tres combien % pour ça
maintenant je peux passer une seule
seconde sans rien faire dès que je
m'ennuie charmant téléphone par exemple
dans un bar avec un pote et qui va aux
toilettes je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
prendre mon téléphone
messi fait là je suis toujours là sympa
le mec qui prend son téléphone alors
qu'il avec son pote tu veux pas le choc
comme ça sur facebook my bonnie devrait
aller non alors les plus touchés sont
les ados bien évidemment qui développent
des symptômes bizarre à cause des
téléphones par exemple ma petite soeur
est touché par ce que j'appelle le
syndrome snap chat c'est à dire on est à
table avec mes parents et comme toutes
les ados elle est ce son téléphone et
attire la gueule quand tout à coup à wil
accessoires obligatoires chez les jeunes
aujourd'hui ce sont les écouteurs je ne
veux pas sortir seul sans mes écouteurs
oh [ __ ] j'ai oublié japon à sanaa au
rebut autre chose
après je peux comprendre que certains
sont dépassés par la technologie ça
évolue tellement vite une nouvelle
application qui s'appelle you et qui
permet d'envoyer à tous ses amis
d'elliot cette application est valorisée
à plus d'un million de dollars nar molle
patron c'est une nouvelle application
qui permet d'envoyer you à tous ses amis
c'est tout oui j'achète un million de
dollars je m'en occupe pas trop il ya
une application qui est d'être lancé
elle s'appelle wesh
c'est pour envoyer des wesh
aujourd'hui les jeunes ils peuvent se
contacter avec n'importe quoi avec les
sms avec facebook avec moi de sap avec
you et s'il ya bien un truc de jeunes
c'est le fait d'envoyer un message à
quelqu'un qui dans la même maison ou
appartement que toi ça arrive et
interoute cyprien allô allô cyprien à
l'eau je suis là un thé à toi ça fait
quinze minutes un non mais tu pourrais
plus me quand même tu es mignon toi même
tu en as grandi avec la technologie avec
les téléphones avec internet c'est ça la
différence avec les yeux nous n'avons
pas les mêmes habitudes
un vieux qui appelle un taxi pas que
c'est un jeune qui appelle un taxi un
vieux qui commande à manger risques pour
commander une pizza s'il vous plaît un
jeune qui commande à manger un vieux qui
fait l'amour un jeune qui fait l'amour
j'aime ça [ __ ] après y'a jeunes et
jeunes je lave ou moi même j'ai grandi
avec des trucs qui ne font pas les mêmes
que ceux des jeunes d'aujourd'hui et ça
fait mal oh [ __ ] super mario bros
l eau est ce que tu veux qu'on joue à
mon premier jeu vidéo montrant des
jeunes mais il n'est pas très beau à
pied pique un peu les yeux c'est quoi
ton jeu mais ça moi aussi mon premier
jeu c'est watchdogs donc si c'était déjà
joué céleste et laisse tomber les
sondages mais peut-être que je suis plus
jeune alors ballester chaud
chez les anonymes aussi nous allons vous
piratez signé dany boon mais non mais
non